Kruija is one of the most mentioned cities in Albanian history.
Kruija lies on the slope of the Kruija mountain, at an altitude of 608 meters above sea level.
Archaeological excavation in the castle of Kruija testifies that the city has been an
Illyrian settlement since 3rd century BC. The village of Zgirtjes, situated in the
vicinities of the city, is thought to be the antique city of Albanopolis,
mentioned by Ptolemaeus in the 2nd century AD. The settlement of Zgirtjes was abandoned
at the beginning of the Middle Ages and its inhabitants found a better protected place
in Kruija by making it this way, the center of the Arboresh culture as it has been testified
also by the objects found in a cemetery dated 6th to 8th century AD. The city is mentioned
for the first time as an episcopal center in a document of 879. Kruija was the center of
the Byzantine garrisons and Byzantine governors until the end of the 12th century. Moreover,
Kruija was the capital of the first Albanian feudal state, 1191,215.
The city flourishes in the 13th and 14th centuries. In the second half of the 14th century,
it is the center of Topii's family with a highly developed trade and craftsmanship.
The houses close to the castle are the oldest which date that time.